hello in this episode of matrix math
we're going to be looking at some
special matrices a diagonal matrix the
identity matrix the symmetric I spell
this wrong symmetric matrix and the skew
symmetric among the most important of
these is probably the identity as it's
used the most but we'll go over all of
them so first of all a diagonal matrix a
diagonal matrix is a square matrix let
me get my tool well I need my tool it's
a square matrix where all the elements
in a row are equal so say this is a 3 by
3 and we have and all the other elements
have to be 0 so it'll look something
like this that is diagonal diagonal am i
spelling it right I don't know yeah I'm
ok this could be any number as long as
they're all the same now this leads
nicely right into an identity matrix
potentially the most important identity
matrix and what's so important about an
identity matrix is it's used frequently
and in all sorts of programming to get
the same result back so you often start
with an identity matrix when you're
multiplying and it is a diagonal matrix
except everything along that diagonal
line is a 1 and everything else is 0
this is a 4 by 4 it looks like we're
going for here
oh my this is this is so far out of line
let's just pretend it's in line and okay
let's see you yeah I hope you get the
point
yeah my cut that's a that's a terrible
matrix but yes everything along the
center line is just not there is a one
the this might be the worst matrix
you're gonna see drawn on this series
also I have another extra zero there
okay how semi proper identity matrix
first row second row third row fourth
row what is this last row we've been
doing sneaking in there alright so it
would look something like that just a
diagonal line all ones the rest zeros it
has to be a square matrix so the
important thing about the identity
matrix is it doesn't matter what order
you multiply with when you're using the
identity matrix so if you have some
matrix named let's see here
just leave this layer delete okay if you
have some matrix a and you times it by
an identity matrix I it's going to equal
the matrix a and if you have it in this
order it is the same thing so often in
programming or in 3d math you'll have an
identity matrix somewhere and it may or
may not change and if it doesn't change
you keep the same result if it does
change you end up with something new so
it's often used as a placeholder for
that reason okay let's move on to the
last two the symmetric
matrix and the symmetric matrix
basically is the same when you transpose
it we did talk about transpose on the
last episode so if you're not familiar
with that check that out
so that means a is going to equal hay
transposed and if you don't remember
what transposes and don't feel like
watching the last episode well you
probably should at least to get a grasp
on if you're not sure basically you turn
the rows into columns and the columns
into rows and if it's symmetric it ends
up being the exact same thing and there
is also skew symmetric bring this over a
little bit skew symmetric and a skew
symmetric it's pretty similar but it
involves negatives so I will read the
definition then I'll show you one so
excuse metric matrix is a matrix that is
equal to the negative of its transpose
so it'll look something like like a
equals negative a transpose in an
example of the of a skew symmetric would
look something like this zero negative 3
4 and then just a regular 3 here and a
negative 4 here and let's just keep this
in a row zeros to make a Z and we'll do
a negative 1 here and a 1 here so as you
can see if you transpose it where this 4
would end up would be negative where
this 3 would end up would be positive or
where this negative 3 would end up would
be positive or this negative 1 would end
up be just a regular one so that is a
skew symmetric that's all we're gonna
cover in this episode hope you enjoyed
they would like to help with the YouTube
algorithm and follow for more of this
series if you'd like to keep learning
matrix matrix math I want to keep going
for quite a while here until I pretty
much cover everything
so this is gonna be a very long running
series we're still in the pretty basics
right now once we get later into the
series I'm going to spread these out a
little more because it's a lot more to
explain once it gets to formulas and
special cases and stuff but until then
I'm gonna keep pounding out a video a
day thanks for watching I'll see you in
the next episode